now let's talk about the legacy fx
market first uh seven trillion a day is
total market or that's what you guys do
like how big i wish i did seven trillion
i was gonna say all right so that's the
whole market a day it's seven trillion
dollars a day so look the way i look at
foreign exchange and you've got a view
on
this
like imagine
that could be crypto if you imagine as
you said to me yesterday that fiat
currency won't be around 20 years well
it's all going to be replaced by crypto
so that's just global trade
right so people making things in
thailand and selling them in home depot
in the us right so you got thai bar
trade or korean one trade versus us
dollars so that can be replaced by
crypto seven trillion dollars a day
two trillion dollars is spot so i i need
dollars for my thai bar today and then
there's people going well hold on a
second
the next tranche of the market two
trillion dollars would be the swap
market so
um hey i'm long-time bot today i don't
need to deliver it today but i want to
win some interest in overnight so i swap
that out
either overnight or on a weekly basis or
a monthly basis all the stuff also
you're seeing in crypto guess what
that's kind of you know the lending
market all the things that the sec are
looking at right now and then you've got
the forward market like i know i need so
that'd be another trillion dollars i
know i need x amount of time up to pay
for my shovels that i'm going to sell in
home depot in a month's time
and and then you have a non-deliverable
market which is kind of i want access to
korea
to india to
indonesia to brazilian real but i can't
have an onshore bank account so i just
invest in the
economic interest effectively of that so
that is the fx market that's what we do
in terms of lmax we operate six
exchanges and
we trade about 30 billion dollars every
day geez so yeah it's big but you know
compared to the whole market there's a
lot more to win yeah yeah yeah
opportunity that's it
you know i said to you you know we did
last year we averaged of that 30 billion
we did one and a half billion a day in
crypto so if i follow your thesis
that'll get bigger and bigger over there
we go yeah so when it gets to three
you'll be ten percent of your daily
volume of confidence
uh explain to me the infrastructure
differences in an institutional exchange
versus a retail exchange there's a lot
of people who watch this who uh i won't
put name names they've got all the
retail exchanges
it's a good enough experience for the
most part uh there's liquidity they're
able to buy and sell the assets they
want sometimes there's a little bit of
high fees sometimes there's downtime you
know whatever but like from a retail
perspective it gets the job done um but
they're also not buying and selling 20
million dollars for the bitcoin i don't
want to speak for the audience they're
very very wealthy obviously
but being wealthier by the minute yeah
yeah that's not what they're really
doing right it might be kind of hundreds
of dollars thousands tens of thousands
of dollars and so uh institutions
obviously have different needs like how
do you think about the difference in the
infrastructure from a retail exchange
so it's almost
i sort of see it horizontal versus
vertical so look i have empathy with
those retail providers right it's a bit
like after the super bowl ad everyone
you know what do you say this is a great
ad and so many people clicked on it or
you say hey they were down for a minute
so if you think about it in retail
they've got to go horizontally they've
got to accommodate for say a million
users online at any one time
um
asking a lot of different questions so
they'll be saying what is the price of
bitcoin what is the price of ethereum
can i see my statement can you show me a
chart hey is there a news feed from the
pomp you know all of these questions i
mean i need to be able to service that
so low latency or speeders
is not the key prerequisite now in
institutional trading
there's three things that matter
does it work
is it fast
is it cool guess what we never get to
the third bit we never get to the cool
bit which is probably where retail is
right so how do you compete how does one
platform compete with another in retail
land well i should be a bit cooler or
offer something a bit better so what
that manifests itself in is i can't have
a down
second i kind of a down millisecond so
lmx digital has been around four years
we haven't had one down millisecond on
the exchange
um
since creation never wow and it's on my
web page by the way you can go to web
status pages just we don't go there
right because we can't go down because
it this was born out of um an ethics
exchange so the biggest banks in the
world so we've got 35 banks connected
all the largest propriety trading firms
in the world connected and they want to
trade in response times that are now
measured in microseconds right so
response times roughly around 70
microseconds less than a millisecond
what's a millisecond everyone it's the
blink of an eye okay so jesus they want
to know that response they want to send
their order in have it acknowledged and
have their trade uh acknowledged within
microseconds now if i'm down for a few
micros or a few millis they just go
somewhere else and they don't come back
so
very simply that's how we
architect our exchange and that's the
vertical thing i answer a
few number of questions
a lot in any one second so i process
sort of non-farm payroll on a 1 30 on
the first friday of the month i probably
process
100 000 orders per second and i've got
to do that sustained for
five minutes
and if i'm losing 100 000 orders per
second for five straight minutes as
people are trading off of data that just
came out around the non-farm payroll
yeah
so
that's probably the key difference if
you think about it all what am i
offering i'm really saying hey do you
want to buy or do you want to sell and
what's the price now not just now now
now what's the price really now and has
it changed really now and by the way you
must confirm to me within a microsecond
that my trade is done
because the biggest risk and you know
the terminology the biggest risk is an
out trade
and you'll see that even on the retail
platforms like hold on a minute i was
trying to buy or i was going to sell am
i done or not your biggest risk is
you're sitting there going hold on a
second am i long 10 or am i short 10
where am i
and invariably if you don't know that
price move is going to be against you so
it's a it's just a different
architecture and i think trying to put
the two together that some of the retail
guys are doing
is tough because it's just a different
layout it's just a different structure
you've got to architect it right
from the beginning you can't suddenly go
to a retail platform hey guys can you
just do what lmax does and process seven
billion orders a day right and make sure
i've got latency and measures measured
in microseconds you can't do it you're
gonna get it right in the first place so
when you think about um a hundred
thousand orders per second for five
minutes uh
how many could you guys handle like
could you handle 250 000 500 000 but
like like how many is like the maximum
amount that you could you know what you
you need to come and work at lmax
because my cto i ask him that question
every month so if i say if we see the
biggest say i think the last one we saw
the biggest spike was about 140 thousand
orders wow you know a second yeah what
was it for so non-fun so he tells me he
tells me um
hey look at that that was that's really
good that was our peak and i went okay
well then you can imagine this market's
gonna expand so you better build it for
500 000. so we're always adding and it's
back to that does it work
is it fast
because they're not going to thank me
institutions i'm not going to thank me
by something hey guys i did double the
orders
but i also doubled or tripled the length
of time your response time
so
you know when it comes to crypto and
we're fortunate i'd like to say we were
prescient but you know we entered
crypto started building it out 2017
launched it in
in 2018 and i just lifted an fx exchange
because guess what bitcoin dollar
ethereum dollar trades a bit like euro
dollar and a bit like cable
and and much less of them
correct and i was like
i said well let's just move that
infrastructure over to bitcoin so when
we have all these spikes and you know
you've seen the liquidations in asia
you've seen what happens on the retail
platforms
i swear everyone calls me so investors
call me
clients call me family call me how did
you cope yesterday i'm like it was a
blip it wasn't even a blip for us i mean
the day the last time when you you
probably read that you know all the
retail exchanges were down
my order rate was about 10 000 a second
for bitcoin but remember it's the same
architecture
right it's the same hardware
as i have in my fx exchanges that can
accommodate 10x so i say right now i
could trade
we could execute every order in the
crypto market today
by none with the occurrence every single
order every single order type it in now
it's done and if anyone disagrees with
that them you know put them in touch
right